in this lecture we consider the most
brutal of explorers the conquistadors
Spanish military entrepreneurs whose
motivation was announced in their very
name conquest these were men not
directly dispatched and controlled by
the monarchy instead they went out to
the new world as freebooters with royal
sanction to seize wealth and lands the
conquistadors toppled entire higher
civilizations mighty empires and they
did so with only a handful of men and
with astonishing speed effectiveness and
brutality as they did so they laid down
one of the foundational legends of
European imperialism for the next four
centuries the story that allegedly a
small group of Europeans could be so
superior to entire masses of native
peoples that they could dominate and
rule them as if it were a fact of nature
and self-evidently right in fact as we
will see in this lecture this was a myth
the conquistadors were successful to a
very great measure because of how they
mobilized other native peoples in this
struggle and they needed local guides
and interpreters to make their way
without finding local allies the
conquistadors would in no way have been
able to achieve their improbable
successes and a lot of effort later went
into actively forgetting the role of
these local auxiliaries and helpers this
foundational myth of the conquistadors
also links up with another durable and
recurring idea the notion that be
knighted local peoples are so primitive
that they always greet European
explorers as gods
you may recall that Christopher Columbus
himself was convinced that Caribbean
people thought he and his men had come
down from the heavens of course two
later scholars it remains unclear how
Columbus found this out given that he
was actually not able to communicate
verbally with the people that he named
Indians and in a later lecture we will
see the
about whether captain cook's demise in
the Pacific had to do with locals
believing him to be divine
what is incontestable is that the
conquistadors became a powerful image
for later centuries and into our day of
heroic will and boundless appetite for
conquest and ruthless self assertion
just think of a famous romantic poem
written by John Keats in 1816 so some
three centuries already after the time
of Cortes which was entitled on first
looking into Chapman's homer in the poem
Keith says that reading Chapman's
translation of the Greek epic for him
was like traveling in realms of gold
with new worlds appearing before him
keeps writes that he felt like the first
conquistador to ever see the Pacific
Ocean across the Isthmus of Panama or in
fact let the poem speak for itself then
felt I like stout Cortez when with eagle
eyes he stared at the Pacific and all
his men looked at each other with a wild
surmise silent upon a peak in Darien
this of course is great poetry but it
represents a terrible historical blunder
it was not Cortes
but Balboa who had trekked across the
jungles and swamps of Panama and in the
year 1513 became the first European to
see the Pacific or as he called it at
the time the South Sea well be that as
it may the fact that Balboa saw the
ocean and then claimed all of it for
Spain tells you a lot about these
conquistadors the wild surmise that was
at work in their minds what drove them
was gain riches in the Americas and
allied with that the prospect of raising
their own often quite humble social
standing by carving out an area to rule
for themselves in the new world they
could be lords instead of merely being
lower nobility or bastard
it's in his voyages of the 1490s
Columbus and his men had found only a
little gold and this actually was a
tremendous worry for Columbus whose
entire journey was promised on what he
could deliver to the Spanish Court and
he had promised many many treasures many
gold resources however when Columbus
traveled in this region he often heard
stories from local peoples of there
being great riches on the mainland to
the west you might actually want to note
this tactic down for future reference
this was a great way of getting rid of
bothersome strangers whatever they're
looking for tell them that it's over
there over there and then hope that they
never come back again
such inexact stories grew into entire
legends of Cities of Gold and this is
what the conquistadors saw it